both Fargo says a computer glitch is
partly to blame for an error affecting
an estimated 500 customers who lost
their homes the giant Bank filed papers
with the Securities and Exchange
Commission last month revealing that it
incorrectly denied 870 loan modification
requests about 60% of those homeowners
went into foreclosure Anna Werner has
been looking into how this happened
Anna good morning good morning those
questions are coming now from
legislators housing advocates regulators
and most importantly the people who lost
their homes people like Jose Aguilar
this is hard for you really hard for you
I can say that it's been very hard for
me it's something that I wouldn't wish
upon anybody these days
Jose Aguilar can only drive by the home
he and his family lost to foreclosure
three years ago the small ranch house in
upstate New York where they wanted to
raise their children see how many times
my kids and I used to run up and down
right our bikes
he says the problems began when he and
his then wife found mold in the house he
tried to remediate it himself but fell a
few months behind on the mortgage
payments so the couple asked their
lender Wells Fargo to modify their loan
to lower their monthly payment at first
they told me okay you know you might be
able to qualify for a loan modification
but he says then came the delays weeks
then months waiting for a decision and
the whole process has started all over
again once he got to the point we were a
year behind finally Wells Fargo turned
them down
so no loan modifications or education
what was your reaction I mean after all
that time at that point I just gave up
he and his wife split up the house went
into foreclosure and with the hit to his
credit aguilar says he found no one
would rent to him at that point my son
and I had to move to the basement of
friend's house what she stayed there for
three months and we had not he had a
couch and my son had a bed
but that was tough I felt I feel it
worthless worth I feel like I let my
family down
then in September of this year nearly
three years later he got a letter from
Wells Fargo dear jose aguilar at red we
made a mistake
we're sorry it said the decision on his
loan modification was based on a faulty
calculation and his loan should have
been approved it was like are you
serious are you kidding me
like he destroy my kid's life and my
life and I he want me to we're sorry
Wells Fargo now says that calculation
error on loan modifications affected 870
customers over an eight-year period
customers who either were denied loan
modifications or were not offered a
modification in cases where they would
have otherwise qualified about 545 of
those customers ultimately lost their
homes to foreclosure at least some of
those people got a check from Wells
Fargo along with the letter in angular's
case it was for $25,000 but its attorney
mark Dan says that doesn't begin to
cover his total losses so how do you
think they came up with the amounts of
money that they handed out to people
that's what we want to find out we want
to find out what went wrong how it went
wrong Elise Cohen is with the National
Consumer Law Center the question is how
did this happen
aren't they supposed to check their
computer programs regularly to make sure
they're accurate this is clearly more
than just a simple computer mistake
Wells Fargo declined to do an on-camera
interview the company could not say how
much money it expects to pay out in
remediation to customers but Jose
Aguilar says it's not just about money
I want Wells Fargo to know that there's
people out there with feelings and
families that try hard to pay their
bills and survive and we're real people
were not just money
Wells Fargo says it plans to work with
each of those customers to reach a
resolution the bank is also offering no
cost mediation meanwhile nonprofit
groups and some legislators are pushing
for more answers Gail a heartbreaking
story Anna you can really still feel mr.
Aguilera's pain it goes to show you
behind all those loan applications there
are people with real lives and money
can't stake out everything right that's
very tough